une journée placée sous le signe de
l'olympisme ici sur l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines ce jeudi 23
juillet valérie pécresse la présidente
de la région ile de france et tony
estanguet
le président du comité paris à 2024 sont
venus visiter un village sportif un
dispositif installé depuis le 14 juillet
ici sur le site
ils sont venus parler sport et bien sûr
des jo de 2024
au programme de ce dispositif était d
animation sportive placée sous le signe
des jeux olympiques pour les jeunes des
centres de loisirs du secteur
en parallèle une exposition sur les cinq
sites des yvelines retenu pour les jo de
2024 a également été mise en place
c'est très important d'en parler pour
plein de raisons d'abord parce qu'il va
nous falloir cinquante mille volontaires
gio dont tous ces jeunes que vous voyez
dans mon au stage tous les collégiens
que la région accueille chaque année aux
mille collégiens en stage d'une semaine
pour avoir un diplôme de volontaires geo
tout ça ça prépare l'organisation des
jeux donc c'est très important de
mobiliser la jeunesse
ces jeunes présents aujourd'hui seront
peut-être également de futurs
spectateurs sur les sites olympiques y
vinoy à l'heure actuelle deux structures
sont certaines de faire partie du projet
2024 c'est le cas du vélodrome nationale
et du golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines pour les épreuves d'équitation
à versailles de vtt il encourait de bmx
sur l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
la décision sera dévoilé en fin d'année
par le comité aujourd'hui on travaille
main dans la main avec les acteurs
locaux ici pour faire en sorte que la
carte des sites de compétition puisse
être maintenue à condition de respecter
trois engagements un engagement de
sobriété budgétaire pas de dépassements
budgétaires
un engagement sur l'héritage comment
est-ce que ces équipements seront
utilisés par la population après les
jeux et un engagement en matière
d'excellence environnementale donc que
ces constructions puisse respecter
quelque part un cahier des charges très
précis
si le cahier des charges est respecté
les yvelines seront l'un des
départements franciliens les plus
représentés lors des jeux olympiques
parisien en terme d'image soeur norme 1
5 milliards de niches c'est une fois
dense et une fois dans notre vie saint
quentin c'est au maximum une fois par
siècle
voilà donc c'est très important pour
saint quentin pour l'image de saint
quentin le village sportif est programmé
jusqu'au 15 août
ici sur l'île des loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines au total plus de
2000 enfants vont participer à cette
opération